now a review of banking culture has been
ditched by the FCA the financial conduct
authority just months after it was
launched it's been seen by many as a
sign of the changing attitude from the
city watchdog and the treasury towards
the banking industry so is the era
so-called banker bashing now at an end
well I'm joined now by servants cable
who was of course business secretary
until May in the coalition government
he's in chepstow very good morning to
your servants well how do you interpret
this ditching of this investigation into
banking culture well taken in isolation
it's perhaps not terribly important that
it's if you take it together with all
the changes of the last few months the
removal of Martin Wheatley the stepping
down of the commitment to deal more
toughly with bankers liabilities they
retreat from Toph anti-corruption law
application of the financial services
industry and the rhetoric which both the
Chancellor and the governor of the Bank
have been using you can see that there's
a concerted approach to take some of the
pressure off the banks and this is
completely wrong because we've seen in
the past how dependent the British
economy is on banking how when the
banking sector goes down through a
responsibility it has massive
consequences and a tough regime of
Investigation the kind of thing that the
FCA were doing and of regulation is
absolutely central hmm well I mean we're
told that it's going to be one-on-one
consultations with the banks instead you
think the overall review ought to be
revived I would certainly like to see it
I mean of course there are other people
like the house the House of Commons
Select Committee which keep a close eye
on on the banking system that it's very
important that the regulars are the
regulators are seemed to have a tough
approach because we see you know a
cultural problem throughout the banking
industry it's partly a problem with the
investment banks which take excessive
risks the old problems with RBS and
Barclays which probably still there and
there's also the culture of selling
where
staff are incentivized to sell products
which of course led to the abuses around
payments protection insurance that's the
cultural problem that this investigation
was supposed to pursue and the problems
are still there so do you think there
has been pressure behind the scenes as
many are indicating that the bankers
have been talking to the Treasury and
saying well listen this isn't really
good for business anymore we paid enough
finds we've had enough banker bashing
and now we need to get on with business
I'm sure pressure has been brought to
bear and it's clearly working I mean in
the coalition years we had a balanced
approach to the banks we had much
tougher regulation requirements to hold
more capital the banks are safer George
Osborne and I pushed through the reforms
which split the investment banks from
traditional banking through ring-fencing
that legislation went through at the
same time being realistic about the need
for the banks to operate commercially
now what's happened now is that the the
balance has gone the bankers are being
listened to their complaints have been
taken on board and a blind eyes being
adopted towards abuses in the system we
had evidence only a few days ago that
the leading investment banks are not
paying taxes here they're making profits
here but they're not paying taxes here
just skimming of large amounts of money
and a traditional argument for having a
strong banking industry in the UK is
that they paid taxes well you know we
can see if that's a longer the case but
since I mean if we look at that equation
if I can call it that there's in the
coalition years there's you the
Chancellor and the bank's the only thing
removed from that equation now is you so
does that mean that George Osborne was
always a reluctant participant in the
coalition years in the the moves against
the banks I think initially he was
totally sincere in accepting the fact
that we had to have a tough regime in
order to make sure we had financial
stability and that the banks played a
role in supporting the productive side
of the economy but I think as times past
the sense of urgency is gone
but this is the dangerous time because
it's when there isn't an immediate
threats of the system the pressure goes
off bad practices creep back in there's
excessive risk-taking abuse in the
investment banking side banks no longer
feel under any pressure from politicians
to support productive lending through
small business now is the crucial time
and I I do worry that the Chancellor and
even the governor no longer appear to
have the same degree of motivation to
make the banking sector work for Britain
and this is all about holding the
government to account and in so many
other areas it's been said that they're
not because of the nature of the
opposition the Labor Party indulged and
preoccupied with so many internal issues
the lib dems your own party cut to
ribbons with only eight MPs do you see a
way back and I don't just mean for the
lib dems do you see a way back for those
that would hold the government to
account and perhaps it would be some new
formation involving your own party and
perhaps Labour MPs at some point in the
future do you see that happening well I
do share your analysis I think we are in
danger in the UK of having a one-party
state because it's a different one party
in Scotland but but throughout the UK
we've got basically Conservative
government not under any real challenge
I think the the co Binh led Labour Party
you know whatever it you know the
personal qualities Jeremy Corbyn has is
nowhere near being a challenge to
government my parties is going to have a
big struggle to get back from where it
is and the issue of accountability and
effective opposition is an absolutely
crucial and now of course out of
parliament but I'm happily engaged with
other people leba party and my own party
trying to create common ground so that
we do in future have effective
opposition the main challenge at the
moment of course will be to have a
common approach to the European Union to
keep us in the European Union but I
think when that referendum is passed the
issue will become absolutely salient
about how do we get a sensible
centre-left opposition to government and
that's going to involve parties working
together but but just parties working
together or perhaps a new formation
well I think that's probably a bit over
the horizon i mean i was part of the
original SDP which ultimately led to the
lib dems i think they're very mixed
feelings about that it you know we had a
long period of conservative government
afterwards think the creation of new
parties new formations is very difficult
in the UK political system I think what
we're looking at in the relatively short
run is practical cooperation with people
who have a common approach that happens
to be in different parties I think
that's the realistic agenda always
fascinating talking to you servants
thank you very much indeed for your time
since cable that adhered to